der Puma Stückpreis 17 Millionen Euro
sollte mal das Vorzeigeprojekt der
Bundeswehr werden schon seit Jahren
allerdings treten massive technische
Mängel an dem Schützenpanzer auf die
neueste Panne nach einer Schießübung mit
18 Pumas war kein einziger mehr
einsatzbereit schwere Elektronikprobleme
zunächst einmal ist der Ausfall der
Pumas bei der jüngsten Übung ein herber
Rückschlag für uns wir waren nach dem
vorangegangenen Übungen noch recht
zuversichtlich weil der Puma sich gut
geschlagen hatte und nun kommt dieser
ungewöhnlich hohe Ausfall besonders
peinlich eigentlich sollten die Pumas ab
dem 1 Januar für die sogenannte NATO
Speerspitze zur Verfügung stehen jetzt
fallen genau die Panzer die extra dafür
nachgerüstet wurden aus wir haben in der
NATO bedeutende Aufgaben und wir haben
im Rahmen der schnellen Eingreiftruppe
hohe Verantwortung zu tragen und
deswegen muss Holland recht jetzt hier
handeln
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht will
statt der Pumas jetzt den 50 Jahre alten
Vorgänger schicken den Schützen Panzer
Marder die Grünen sind Regierungspartner
in der Ampel und fordern von Lamprecht
tiefgreifendere Formen bei der
Bundeswehr die Puma setzen bei Manövern
ist sehr bedenklich und zeigt dass wir
ganz dringend und überfälligerweise eine
andere Art der
das materialmanagements und auch der
Beschaffung bei der Bundeswehr brauchen
vor einer Stunde meldet das
Verteidigungsministerium zumindest die
Anschaffung neuer Pumas wird ausgesetzt
so lange bis sich der Panzer als
tauglich erweist